welcome into safety blitz i feel like
that sound right there almost was the
complete story even just the let's go
from mcveigh walking away everything
they were faced with no ramsay no higbee
no daryl henderson no rob havenstein the
right tackle i mean that's some tough
hits to take right before that game
what'd you think of the way that the
rams responded on the football field
the rams mindset was completely
different it was more physical you look
at what they did offensively they came
out with six offensive alignment at
times and sean mcvay he understands now
that you can't reach a super bowl with
this finesse stuff you got to be able to
get it down there run the football add
extra linemen if you have to and on the
defensive side of the ball they were
physical flying around aaron donald did
his thing but sean mcvay finally gets it
that's why he's so pumped up because
he's like my team finally played
physical and i thought he had a great
game plan
and also you're starting to see odell
beckham jr come into this fold and i
think it's the perfect style of coaching
from sean mcveigh i don't know if you
saw that clip sort of go viral last week
of mcveigh and jefferson the way he was
coaching him on the sideline he just has
this love and appreciation for his
players it makes everybody feel that
love
and i think odell beckham jr has come in
with a team first mindset and stafford's
been the right quarterback for him it's
not like they're trying to force him his
touches they're just coming within the
offense which seems to be the perfect
way to get obj going and last night he
looked fast he looked quick he looked
explosive yeah we haven't really seen
that after all of these injuries that he
suffered
absolutely and i was about to say the
same thing he looked fresh he looked
free he looked like he was excited about
playing football i remember talking to
him earlier this year when we were in
atlanta and he didn't seem really
excited you know he seemed down he
seemed like he was doubting himself but
now he's playing with a lot more
confidence um he's a legitimate weapon
and if you know and what happens with
cooper cup cooper cup they're using him
and that's one of my concerns how much
they're using cooper cup and i would say
maybe rotate you know odell beckham in
that slot a little bit because he's
played in that slot and he's very
effective when he when he's in there
it was cool to see sony michelle out
there getting getting you know the bulk
of this workload too sony michelle runs
hard he's a physical running back then
you get henderson back then you got the
combination of both of those guys i want
to flip it to arizona quickly kyler
murray has played basically his two
worst games in prime time the thursday
night game where they lost to green bay
now he comes back on monday night loses
to the rams without a whole bunch of
players kyler murray's performance
overall what did you see from him
man i just you know when you watch colin
murray he's a really good player
obviously and he can he could put a lot
of pressure on the defense but it can't
be one of those situations jack where
he's dropping back and he's running
around trying to create plays you know
and that's that's the thing that throws
me off when he's when he drops back four
or five yards and he throws the ball i
really like that but once he starts
running around and you know trying to
create all these different plays that's
where i get concerned yes you're gonna
have plays where it's unbelievable we
say oh my god can you believe that play
that cali murray made but there's going
to be other instances when he's a young
quarterback he's going to force the ball
like he did and throw a couple
interceptions you can't have that i told
you last week i said it comes down to
his speed being able to control his
speed and also his decision making and
he has to be better i'm gonna tell you
one guy that i was really really excited
to see and that was um james connor
james connor he's gone through when he
was with pittsburgh he went through a
lot of adversity with all the different
injuries and it was just really good to
see him back playing because i was one
of those guys that doubted him like man
can james connor still play but now he
looks faster he looks stronger he looks
like he's a receiver catching one hand
passes now you can take him out of the
backfield you could put him in the slot
or you can bring him out of the
backfield and he can catch the ball we
know how tough and physical he is as a
runner i'm just so happy and excited for
james connor
yeah i i am right there with you i
couldn't believe that he was running the
full route tree i mean he's lining up
there in the slot and he's running every
route ziggs ends outs comebacks he's
down the field 10 yards to get in the
football and that way nine catches for
94 yards is what he finished the game
with but probably the biggest thing when
you watch him play is that he doesn't go
down with one guy it takes two or three
hats around the football if you're going
to get him down and it's a contract year
for him you know just signed that one
year deal there in arizona still having
to prove it even with the success that
he had in pittsburgh and i think he has
proven something here ronnie you think a
team may take a chance and sign him to a
couple of years
on a contract here and give him a chance
to be the featured man based on what
you're seeing what
well it better be arizona that's where
you want to go and sometimes a change of
scenery environment is good and we see
it this is a perfect fit because he's
one of those guys he doesn't care he's
the ultimate team player he doesn't care
if he gets the ball two times or if he
gets it 25 times he's going to do any
thing it takes to you know be productive
for the team i like this kid man really
excited for him
i do too aj green had a big game for
them as well over 100 yards but i
thought the biggest thing watching this
game was that this this rams defensive
line this rams pass rush is overwhelming
and we knew it would take a little bit
of time for von miller for aaron donald
to develop the chemistry one sort of
from the inside one coming around the
outside
but that chemistry is starting to form
now and these are some pure athletes
that are rushing guys like tyler murray
and we've seen kyler murray escape and
beat linebackers and even beat defensive
backs at times with pure speed but
athletes like donald and like von miller
are a whole different level we saw that
play itself out this is the best pass
rush in all of football and they took
over this game early often and even late
when they needed big moments tip passes
you name it whatever they needed this
defensive line was coming up with it
yeah and a lot of times too even if it's
not the sack it's the pressure because
he sees those guys trust me he knows
where number 99 is at he knows where
number 40 is at he knows where leonard
floyd is at and these guys are fast
they're all fast they're all long and
athletic and they get after you aaron
aaron donald what i mean what can you
say man we talk about michael parsons
but this guy man he's still the best
defensive player i've seen in my
generation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports